hello welcome to today's live webinar
software for microbial genome assembly
and analysis today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website provided with virtual events and
webinars that advance scientific
collaboration already it's brought to
you by DNA star for more information
about DNA star please visit
www.canadianoutback.com enter a question
into the Q&A box that appears on the
screen also the presentation will be
shown in slides in the slide window you
can enlarge the slides by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right of
the slide window and finally if you have
any technical difficulties viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button and the upper
right of the presentation window let us
know what's going on by using the Q&A
button on the far left and try to fix
the situation as quickly as possible now
I'd like to present today's speaker
Matthew Kaiser from DNA from DNA star
Matthew is a senior manager of next-gen
sequencing applications at DNA star he
has worked there for the past eleven
years and for the last eight years his
focus has been on next-generation
sequencing
please join me in welcoming Matthew to
today's presentation
thank you Bob and thank you for joining
us this afternoon so today I'd like to
focus on one of the NGS what flows in
the DNA star software Suites and that
will be microbial genome assembly and
analysis before I get into the workflow
I'd like a little bit of background on
DNA star for those of you that aren't
familiar with us we're located in
Madison Wisconsin we have a nice picture
here of our Capitol in Lake Monona and
it actually looks like that today
oftentimes this lake is covered with ice
and snow but it is nice and warm today
so DNA star produces many different
types of software we're going to really
focus in the genomics area today
but we have three main areas molecular
biology structural biology and genomics
and we have a comprehensive suite of
software then for each one of these key
areas the molecular biology area
provides many different tools for things
like multiple sequence alignment of
sequence visualization and editing we
have nice colorful output for many of
our different programs and really a
powerful palette of tools for working
with both DNA and protein sequences we
also have some new protein analysis
tools we have an award-winning protein
folding algorithm program called Miller
fold and some excellent visualizations
of proteins we do have webinars on these
other topics if you visit our website
you can see multiple other web webinars
that cover these these topics today
again the focus is on genomics and in
particular it will be microbial genome
assembly and analysis and so our genomic
software includes both assembly software
and visualizations and annotation
software and you'll look at some screen
captures and we'll go through that in
some detail later in the webinar
DNA star has been producing research
grade software for a number of years if
we look at the number of publications we
have
then twice twice as many as their
nearest competitor so we've been in the
market for quite some time producing in
research grade software one of the key
aspects to DNA star software in a you
know in addition to the software people
we produce is the support that we can
provide and we have worldwide support we
had office hours
here in central time zone from 7 a.m. to
6 p.m. and we have global locations as
well so we had distributors of our
software throughout the world so you can
generally get a hold of a DNA star rep
by phone by email by chat we also do a
live webinars one on one to support our
customers we also have recorded monthly
webinars that are on specific topics and
so and they're archived as well so if we
don't happen to cover a topic today that
that you would like to learn more about
this is a great resource on our website
and you can go through you know all the
way back to 2012
these hour-long webinars that go through
a variety of topics both most mgs and
molecular biology and protein analysis
in in some detail we also have an
extensive video library on our website
the videos our YouTube videos that are
anywhere from between one and maybe
eight minutes long they're on all
different topics so you can see that we
have things in cloning and gene
detection NGS workflows we have within
the NGS workflows there are specific
workflows to different platforms ion
torrent or lunar impact bio and so forth
so these are again great resources to
learn more information about specific
topics
so our NGS software is compatible with
all the NGS platforms right now it's
primarily Illumina PacBio and ion
torrent 454 is being phased out we are
looking ahead to to some of the Nana
port technologies and so as that
technology enters the market we will
have tool that we're compatible with any
of the future long.we technologies as
well this is one of the key
points for our commercial software is
that we can handle all different types
of data and so most software open source
software in particular would be specific
to a certain data type so it is flexible
enough to accommodate all the different
platforms and all the different
different specific qualities that these
sequence reads might have our software
also has flexible access so we give you
different options for where and how you
can run the software that can include
software that runs on a desktop computer
to network licensing the key server
licenses so you can install the software
on multiple computers to give access to
many different people that can share
licenses we also have cloud workstations
so you can run our assemblies up on the
Amazon Hardware assemblies in the cloud
you can also have assemblies up on the
Amazon or use any of our software on an
Amazon workspace computer so if you are
constrained with the hardware that you
have these are great options or if
you're traveling or you just don't have
access to your your desktop or your
laptop computer the cloud options are
really nice options for you so to run
our NGS software there are some hardware
requirements we try to design the
software to be optimal running on a on a
modest computer so for example you know
a laptop computer with 16 gigs of RAM
and a hard drive that can handle scratch
excuse me temporary files that we call a
scratch disk we could plug that into a
laptop and have some storage and we can
do things like human axle assemblies or
RNA seek assemblies I can also just run
use my laptop and run my assemblies up
on the Amazon Hardwick and launch the
assembly locally so it really gives us
nice flexibility then in in assembling
NGS data you do not need a big powerful
Linux workstation or cluster to do these
assemblies and alignments you know
really these modest computers any again
if you don't have the hardware you can
get access to the Amazon Cloud and the
user experience is very similar to
running a local assembly you
set the assembly up on your your laptop
computer what happens then is the data
uses a secure protocol to upload it to
the DN a star Cloud Drive and the Amazon
server and then the assembly runs up on
the Amazon hardware and there's some
advantages here beyond just not having
Hardware one of the advantages is you
can run multiple concurrent assemblies
so for example if I have 50 human exomes
that each take a couple of hours to run
I can launch all 50 at one time and the
next day at 50 really in a few hours 50
completed human exome project so it is
very very convenient way to do
assemblies so one of the first questions
that we get with any kind of desktop
software in particular is what is the
performance you know you know can a
modest piece of hardware you know
compete in terms of performance speed
with soccer running on much more
expensive and powerful hardware and so
I'd love to show this this benchmark and
the Mensch mark has human genome let's
see I'll just try to grab up so you can
see human genome at 36 X coverage about
12 hours for assembly time and what this
time includes is both the alignment of
the data to the reference genome all the
snip calculations so the creation of all
the snip files and building all the BAM
output files that are visualized
downstream to the DNA start software so
it's really from start to finish you
know roughly a 12-hour assembly time
smaller projects like human exomes take
under two hours so a 50x coverage human
exome you know it'll call it a couple of
hours and things like cancer panels or
microbial genomes we measure those in
minutes so smaller data sets are very
very quick and that really means you
know you can run a large number of
samples again unfairly modest hardware
the other aspect to our software is the
accuracy and it's really really been the
focus for DNA star for the past a little
bit over a year has been to improve the
accuracy as much as as possible and
right
we we have an accuracy of about
ninety-nine point seven percent for snip
detection in human data set so these are
large validated data sets there's a link
to our white paper on our website where
there's a comparison of our software to
the Illumina standard which is a bwa
aligner and gatk snip collar and so
there's a link there that can show you
how we did the comparison it's using the
genome in a bottle data set the
reference data set that's highly
validated so you have that a really
really accurate answer in order to
determine that your accuracy is close to
100% and it wasn't until that data set
was made available that we were able to
really fine-tune both the aligner and
the snip collar to get what we think is
the most accurate assembler and snip
collar on the market so our software
supports all the different NGS workflows
and so what I'm showing you here is the
starting point for our workflows and
that's in Sikma engine and so Sikma an
engine is a 64-bit program that runs on
Mac PC and Linux and you can see we can
choose different project types and you
know ranging from genome assembly to
exome two panels transcriptome chip seek
viral host integration metagenomic so as
you make your selections this is really
a project setup wizard if you make a
selection for genome assembly the next
wizard page will be choose the type of
genome assembly and that's what we're
gonna focus on today are the types of
genome assemblies and the different
tools that our software can offer and so
that includes a templated assembly that
produces Aban output file and we also
have a de novo option so that uses 8 to
know algorithm and then there's some
other we won't go into detail of the
automated gap closure but there's some
other algorithms here as well for
specific types of projects so for
microbial genome assembly closure an
annotation visualization there is some
questions that need to be answered
early on in me in the process and I
spend
a good amount of my time working with
customers through different types of
projects and microbial genomes are often
challenging because it's not always
clear what the best approach is to
assemble the genome so for example some
genomes have very close reference
genomes and really the differences are
just snip like so the easiest type of
assembly is when the only differences
are a handful of snips you can use the
reference genome to guide the assembly
and that produces an output file then
where you can just export a consensus
and get your new genomic string on the
opposite opposite end of that spectrum
are organisms that do not have anything
close at all and me in the in the
databases and so if you have a more
novel organism then really the approach
has to be more de novo so it may be a de
novo assembly followed by a de novo
closure and annotation and those can be
quite difficult and then there's some
that are in between where it's not and
that's where most of them lie are kind
of in between we're not really sure do
we have a reference genome or do we have
to go de novo and most customers pride
just kind of fall in the middle and
that's where the support at DNA star
really helps we can look at a project
quickly to turn what the best path is
for you and then our software can
provide solutions to both paths so we'll
start with what's on the easier side of
the spectrum and that's reference guided
assembly and so again with our seat bed
engine we start by creating a new
assembly project we pick Janome assembly
templated normal workflows so each time
we click the next button and it advances
us we enter a project name
and we add our input files and at this
point is where we pick the best possible
reference genome
sometimes it's unknown what the best
possible reference genome is and we do
have some tools I don't have the slides
to show you but for example I could pick
a metagenomic workflow and our aligner
can easily align your sequence data to
4,000 bacterial genomes all at one time
you know and so on in a couple of hours
we can take an unknown sample and figure
out what the best possible reference
genome is so again that's it that's a
different workflow there's also I could
load VCF files in so you may have a
reference genome that has a list of
variations that are interesting or
positions along the reference that are
of interest the VCF file keeps track of
those positions if you have a VCF file
you can use that to enhance your
analysis or alternatively you can create
a VCF file in our software so if you
align to a reference genome find
differences we can find those through a
snippet port and say creating the CF
file from those differences so we work
well DNA start works well with novel or
non-model organisms by creating VCF
files which are typically only available
for them for model organisms so once
we've picked the reference genome we
select the read technology in this case
I had Illumina data and I've loaded in
paired data and it'll prompt you for a
pair distance that's the distance
between the forward and reverse pairs
I've loaded in too fast queue files here
Illumina fast queue and then actually
make their data so they're about well
excuse me these are paradigm data so
they're 500 base pairs apart you could
have make their data could be five
thousand base pairs apart the algorithm
will use that information to help with
structural variant analysis in a de novo
assembly that's what we'll use to create
genomic scaffolds there's some basic
assembly options here with Illumina data
we generally just stick with
what's default or but I would change
genome ploidy
to haploid which is not done on this
wizard and that really just affects the
snip calling so we'll get a some
accurate genotyping corals if we can
select the correct genome ploidy here
there's some Advanced Options as well
that I'm not going to go into but
there's some more knobs and dials we can
adjust to improve our assemblies so at
this point the assembly is ready to
begin and we get a script file that's
written that guides the assembler and
when we click assemble we can watch the
progress of the assembly and then when
it's done we get an output file that we
can work with in the downstream DNA star
tools so here is a view and our Sikma
and software and again this is a this is
a close easy reference genome and the
way I know that is by looking at these
different views so for example this is a
strategy view and these thick green
areas you can see it says depth of
coverage and pair consistency so this is
a histogram of the coverage across that
reference genome and you can see it's
about kind of hard to see on my screen
it's a little bit small but it's about
50x coverage across the genome and
you'll notice that it's pretty even
across that genome maybe there's a hint
of a gap here maybe not it might just be
a thin area so when I do my assembly I
can immediately open the project up and
then assess the quality of the assembly
so what I'm looking at is depth of
coverage across the genome there's also
a pair consistency plot like a little
arrow there and that is the pair
coverage so that is the four numbers
pairs do they have coverage across the
whole reference genome if they don't
there will be gaps there so if there's
differences structural variations you'll
see gaps you'll see other artifacts
where there's no pair consistencies
across a novel insertion element so they
show up pretty clearly and I'll show you
some examples of that too what I have a
couple of kind of screenshots of pair
distances it's a strip
variation report so the structural
variation report is showing at its
circle here but thirty-five structural
variations total in the whole genome
that's a relatively small number and the
snip report right here shows 29 snip
positions and I can look at those snip
positions and just see well there's a
handful of snips but 29 snips across you
know a 5 mega base genome that means
these genomes are very very close
together so I can quickly assess and say
these are close enough that if I want to
produce my new genome all I have to do
is export a consensus sequence out and
begin annotation where so this is
showing the kind of the easy easiest
case and so from our software I can
export to another program that gives me
different views this is a fully editable
seat builder program where I can look at
circular Maps linear maps I can adjust
features move features around on the map
name them apply restriction enzymes
create nice pictures and again I can
manually annotate here or blast and
bring annotations and so there's a
number of different ways that I can
annotate these sequences so now if I did
the same assembly but picked a different
reference genome so if I pick one that
was more distant these same views would
look quite a bit different and if I look
at the strategy view I'll see now that
there's this depth of coverage histogram
there's lots of gaps right and you can
then they really pop out and I can also
see my pair consistency now also has
gaps and there's some red on the bottom
side of the graph those are pairs that
are not the expected distance apart
again that's evidence that there's
something going on like a structural
variation so these may be deletions it
could be insertion sites the excuse me
the structural variation report right
here shows me now that I have over 3,000
excuse me
1000 structural variations here and 1000
they're structural variants on microbial
genome that's indicates that it's a you
know pretty distant
reference Gino and the sniffs we've got
46,000 snips now all right so I take
that evidence together and say well this
Gino probably isn't close enough to
really guide the assembly you know maybe
a de novo approach is a better approach
so customers that are using our software
I say you know try both do it de novo
assembly align to the best possible
reference then we analyze the results
and pick the path of least resistance to
complete you know closing the genome and
the annotation work so the de novo
project set up in sequin engine is has
some different inputs that are required
and you can see there's de novo assembly
and then there's also one that uses it's
kind of a hybrid between reference
guided and de novo assembly if you have
mate pair data and your reference genome
is reasonably close you know under
definitely under a thousand structural
variations you can use this kind of a
hybrid approach as well
and but now we're just going to focus on
de novo assembly looks like the genome
we had is quite different so we're going
to see what what happens when we just do
a de novo approach so again the
project's setup we name the file the
project now is going to save as a Sikh
man Pro project file this is a fully
editable format it has a limit though of
about 10 million reads can maybe stretch
that to 15 million reads so for shorter
sequence of sequencing technologies like
aluminum it really limits this fully
editable bonobo project to small
eukaryote 200 mega bases and under and
of course you can do all the microbial
genomes Longley technology though 10
million reads covers a much much larger
genome so then medium sized eukaryotic
genomes are possible it's still not the
largest eukaryotic genomes but it allows
us have editable project files for much
larger genomes we have long read
technology and then we can also save
things like contigs and unassembled
reads we have several different options
here the novel algorithms are different
than alignment to reference genomes so
there are some different input required
we also need to trim the data so there's
all different kind of cleanup operations
here so there's quality trim vector trim
contaminant scans remove repeats there's
a button here for advanced trim scan
options brings up a whole page of
fine-tuned kind of training that we can
do most of the genomic data sets
especially from from aluminum are quite
clean so it's usually not necessary to
do too much trimming beyond quality
scores other DeNoble assemblies like
cDNA for RNA seek those tend to have
more linkers adapters primers still
stuck on the sequences we tend to use
these trimming tools more for those
types of datasets so once we once we get
to this point we have some we enter an
expected genome length and there's some
additional options minimum match
percentage and mer size and really it's
this minimum match percentage that sets
the overall stringency for the de novo
assembly much like the reference guided
assembly it's a single most impactful
parameter so for example in a de novo
assembly if I change this value here
from 93 to 83 for example what will
happen is reads will stick together that
might not go together similar genes my
cluster together I may actually get
bigger content much bigger contexts
however they they'll often times contain
false joins and so there's a balance
between getting the largest possible
context and the accuracy of those
contexts and we find that about a 93%
match for a limited data is a pretty
good balance and what that matches that
is the aligned reads to the consensus
for that context and so this is a pretty
good balance we can also call out small
contexts and there's more advanced
options that we won't go into here it's
we really have a lot of control over how
this de novo assembly is going to run
when the assembly is complete again it
can be opened directly in our Sikh man
software
and here's a couple of windows that are
typical places that we will do our
analysis so you've got I'll just kind of
show you this project report on the left
we can see the version of software that
was used the assembly time this took
about eight minutes we see the number of
contexts the number of con kegs to reach
the genome size that's that's what I
like to look at this case it's 68
contexts which is pretty reasonable for
an e coli genome and using alumina data
now as we get better data longer more
accurate reads this number is going to
drop 68
quickly drops to you know 25 if we have
the longest most accurate Illumina data
if we start using things like PacBio
data you know you could get one it for
some genomes 1 content assembled or it
could just be a handful of contexts you
know under 10 contexts that reach that
genome size then the content of 50 of
course is related to the context size
the bigger that number is the better off
you are and then there's some other
metrics here in the project report that
tell us how our DeNoble Assemblyman we
also get a contact list I can see this
contact list this is the summary and I
can see you know some of these contacts
are well over 200,000 base pairs long
and contain tens of thousands of
sequences and this view is interactive
then with the alignment views and so
down the bottom here that's just the
align data and that's fully editable
so this is a Seikh man project file and
so I can go in and do micro edits I can
edit the consensus I can edit individual
sequences it's a great great tool for
interacting now with disassemble data
and working with it and so the micro
editing I can actually be done many
different way it's hard to show it in
slides it's you know in which we have
live software you can it's a little bit
more dynamic but I think you get the
idea here's a spot that's highlighted
what is an ambiguous place in the
consensus and I use this search tool in
our software to find conflict searches
so or differences between the consensus
and the Orion greens
and there's a little Chevron's down here
in the window and I can move very
quickly to find these regions where
there's a problem with the consensus
call so I can go through the whole set
of contexts make micro edits and type in
what the correction might be or I might
not be able to do that I might say well
I can't tell what it should be there
maybe we have to you know you know a
Sanger run or something to confirm what
that is in that in that region so it's a
great place to do micro editing we can
also do contact editing so micro editing
is at the base pair level I can also
look at the context strategy views and
this is usually where I start is I just
open up the strategy views for all the
context scroll through them very quickly
if there's a problem with the Conte it
shows up it really sticks out with this
lower plot where you get this area like
this that's a with a pair consistency
just doesn't exist and that's a real
strong indicator that there's a problem
with that context so I can place my
cursor right in that spot and go to my
menu to split the contig it'll just
break this in the two pieces um I can
also look at the content and in some
cases some context depending on the data
set there could be some noise right in
the very end of the content may be a bad
read or a chimeric read or that prevents
the content from building larger I need
to select the whole range hit delete and
trim off the end so again these are more
editing contexts and masses of sequences
which is a nice clean up to do before
you get closure once I've done that I
can create scaffolds there's an
algorithm so our software does it in two
steps it does the assembly it lets me
look at the assemble context clean them
up if needed visualize them once I'm
satisfied I have the most accurate
possible context I can create these
scaffolds and our algorithm reads the
the mate pair of the pair data on the
ends of the context that's what these
light blue you kind of see them right
here those numbers are pretty small but
you can see there's some numbers there
those are the numbers to leave for the
contact that is just upstream where the
mate pair is residing and so our
algorithm reads this information and
builds a scaffold off that information
and that results in what we have here or
contact 27 is next to contact 33 and
there's a whole bunch more scaffolds and
now I have these dark blue these little
hash marks are actually these are the
mate pairs that were used to build the
scaffold so we can visualize all of this
then and really get a visual
confirmation that everything is put
together properly so it's an excellent
tool for visualizing editing and then at
this point resolving the genome we can
not focus on the gaps and resolve those
gaps using additional editing tools and
software and so we have gap closure
tools and the gap closure tools are
again in our Sikh men software so we can
go in again here's a contact 33:30 and
47 and they're separated by a gap that
we know is within the fragment has to be
within our mate pair distance so if we
had aluminum NextEra make pair data here
that's 5 KB apart we know that the
element the piece in there has to be
less than 5 KB and so we're looking for
a fragment to fill that in and there's
all different ways to do that some folks
will take you know design primers and
generated in an epoch on you know occur
and then sequence the amplicon to fill
the gaps in that's one way another way
before you do that you might blast the
edges of these contexts and figure out
where in the genome this gap is
occurring any coli for example they
often occur at is elements so it may be
possible excuse me just to plug in an is
element align it together and then
confirm the accuracy by reassemble in
the data so it's kind of an iterative
process per gap of course this is a more
labor-intensive process closing gaps so
ideally you have as few gaps left as
possible so again that's we're having
really the longest reads that you can
get the most accurate reads will result
of de novo assemblies the fewest gaps
because you you can figure at least you
know an hour of your time you know
closing each gap manually if not more if
you're if you're not an experienced
genome closure closure person so in our
software we can identify these gap areas
we can generate sequence fragments you
know it could be a bi data it could be a
blast fragment from a reference genome
we can add them enter these sequences
into sequin and so we get this list of
avi sequences here and then we can use
the algorithms within seek man to splice
these sequences into these gap regions
and merge these contexts together and so
it's a you know a powerful process and
we can you know slice them together
export it consensus out again realign
all the data and if you did everything
correctly you should get a perfectly
aligned set of data through the splice
site if you made a mistake it might look
like there's a structural variation
there you might not have a pair
consistency you may have mismatches and
so forth so it becomes this kind of an
inner process so you really need a tool
like seek man that gives you this visual
kind of feedback and a way to layout the
project to really work on the
deficiently once the gaps are closed now
then you can move on to things like
annotation work and so the annotation
can be done a number of different ways
one way is right in our C command
software where we can blast we can blast
our context and then get blast hits with
all different kind of scores and there's
a button here collect features I can
collect features then from those blast
hits and these features then will be
pulled onto the consensus of that of
that blasted region so I can if I do
have relatively close sequences in the
databases I could pull those into the
project and auto auto annotate that
consensus
once I've done that again I can bring I
could bring those annotations to send
them right over to seat builder which
provides all the types of annotation
tools I can really focus on individual
features so I can select say a feature
and in a linear map like this and you
can see I get all the information you
know down below about that feature so
seat bill there is a great annotation
tool for making it look nice I can have
all different features colored I have
CDSs here that are blue and jeans that
are green in a source feature I can make
a linear map I think design primers here
there's a lot of things I can do in seat
builder to embellish the annotation work
we also have tools for novel gene
finding and so novel gene finding I know
these fonts are really small but if you
have a genome that you can't blast you
because it's essentially a novel genome
has very weak blast hits you can use the
gene discovery tools and you can see
here we've got at the top we've got open
reading frame detection and so we can
apply these methods on the left hand
side and they are displayed then in the
end to be we call the assay surface in
the middle so I can apply things like
worth detection stop-and-start detection
I can bring in features so here we can
see here two features that came in
through my blast but here's a region in
the middle that doesn't have any
features as a blank area so that would
be a spot where potentially there's a
gene feature there but I have to
discover what it is so I can apply
things like these artboard Oskie plots
look for likely coding regions with high
DNA complexity and you can see this kind
of a plot here it looks suggest that in
this area there's some you know a gene
in that area so I can use the tools here
to identify exactly where that gene
starts and stops and hand annotate these
kind of novel areas or confirm areas
that I've gotten
through other methods to you know verify
that their exact gene regions so once
I've done the annotation I can move on
to genome visualization and again
multiple different ways I can look at
the genomes and DNA star software we
have the seek builder maps which give me
linear and circular Maps I also have
this little picture here of this is our
gen vision software that can produce
kind of these publication quality and
they're really nice for microbial genome
kind of mappings so that we can have
information tracks kind of all to scale
and bring them in together from
different areas the DNA software to make
this really nice map so with that I'd
like to thank everybody for joining
today if there are any questions I will
be I'll stick around here for the next
10 10 to 15 minutes to answer any
questions that have come through and I
do have my email on where you can you
can reach me and I'll be for the next
couple of days we'll be answering any
questions that anyone might have so
again thank you well thank you Matthew
for that informative presentation it's
Q&A time for Q&A now and if if you have
questions that you'd like to ask Matthew
please do so now just click on the Q&A
button in the lower left of the
presentation window enter your question
or comment into the new the box that
appears on the screen and fix in it and
yeah so send them now so that if we can
get to them if there are no questions
I would want to skin like to thank
Matthew Kaiser for joining us today and
giving his presentation and and turn the
presentation back to Matthew if you have
Matthew if you have any final comments
and you'd like to make them now wait
hang on a second there's a question I do
have a question and the question is can
DNA stars separate out multiple tag
sequences for a pool of specimens so our
software so typically that's done with
barcodes so we usually will recommend
using the Illumina or ion torrent de
multiplexing software you know to
separate the sequences in the discreet
fescue files once that's done our
software does have a complete capability
to handle multiple sample projects so
for example I could have a hundred
bacterial samples and set these the
assembly up in one big multiple assembly
kind of a project for the analysis if
there are no any are there any other
questions anybody would like to ask now
is the time now is your opportunity if
there are none Matthew do you have any
final comments joining me today and you
know in a really keep an eye on DNA
style and have some new tools coming out
here later this year and early in 2016
for de novo assembly and long lead
technology and again I'd be happy to
answer any questions if they come up you
know in the next few days feel free to
call me or send me an email
thank you once again Matthew for your
presentation today and as special thanks
to our audience for joining us for
today's event I'd also like to thank
that roots for making this presentation
possible and finally I'd like to thank
our sponsor Dean a star for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go one more thing I want let
everybody know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through February 2016 that roots will
send you an email inform you as to win
that webcast is available for replay
please does pass this along to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
presentation that's all for now thanks
again I hope to see you soon goodbye